I've been working
in the fingerprint field
now for over 20 years.
Although it can be really intricate
and time-consuming work,
it is just so fantastic when
you actually make a match.
Most of us probably think that
we've got a pretty good understanding
of the basic principles
of forensic science.
We binge on true crime TV series,
we read and buy huge numbers
of books,
and obsessively download
true crime podcasts,
trying to figure out whodunnit.
But there are some things
about forensic science
that you will probably only know
if you're an insider.
Let's start with some basics.
Where does all the information a
forensic scientist needs come from?
Well, everywhere really.
In the early 1900s,
French criminologist, Edmond Locard,
declared that every contact
leaves a trace.
This forms the basis
of what is now called
'Locard's exchange principle'
which says that whatever
you interact with,
you leave something behind
and take something away.
One of the areas of forensic science
where this is particularly applicable
is forensic botany.
There are around 390,000 different
species of plants in the world,
each with its own pollen type,
and when it comes to crime scenes,
pollen can really tell a story.
It's all around us,
it's on the ground,
if you walk on soil or vegetation
you pick it up,
inevitably you pick it up.
Patricia Wiltshire
is a forensic ecologist,
she uses pollen to help solve crimes.
Unlike other forms of evidence,
pollen isn't easily washed away.
It gets into clothes and it can often
be found on shoes
or on the foot pedals in cars.
Pollen and spores are too small
to be seen by the naked eye,
so criminals rarely realise
that they've picked them up
at a crime scene.
Pollen and spores are produced
by plants and fungi.
They grow in specific places,
so you know very well that this plant
will grow in this soil,
that plant will grow in that soil,
and because of that, we can predict
where they are from.
In one particular case
of an attempted murder,
this man tried to strangle a girl
underneath a lamp post
and he said he hadn't been there,
of course,
but by taking his clothing apart,
I showed that he'd bumped up against
a fence with his left shoulder,
that he'd dragged her
through a hedge,
that he'd knelt, and so on.
And because I sampled
the crime scene in detail,
I could see where
bits of his body had been
so I could actually reconstruct
what he did at the time.
There are other ways in which nature
can help forensic scientists
determine when a crime was committed.
Insects, for example, can provide
a lot of information
if you know what to look for,
as forensic entomologist,
Amoret Whitaker, explains.
When you die your body starts
to break down and decompose
basically straight away. And so your
body starts giving off certain odours
and those are very attractive
to blowflies.
If we can work out how old the larvae
are that are feeding on the body,
then we can work out the minimum time
that that person must have been dead.
The colder it is, the slower the
larvae develop,
the warmer it is,
the faster they develop.
Really, the shorter the time span
since the death,
the more accurate we can be.
Remember Edmond Locard, the French
criminologist we mentioned earlier?
His contribution to forensic science
didn't end at
"everything leaves a trace".
He developed and contributed to
various methods of forensic analysis,
including dactylography,
the study of fingerprints.
The interpretation of evidence
has changed a lot
since I became a crime scene examiner
20 years ago.
Back then, if I examined a car whose
door had been broken open
to gain entry, and the
only evidence I found
was a fingermark on the
outside of the driver's door,
I could reasonably expect
that if the fingermark was
identified for someone,
then that person would eventually
be charged with the offence
and the case would go to court.
However, things are
now very different.
If the same fingermark
was found today,
especially in a relatively
non-serious case such as this,
there would be a strong likelihood
that it wouldn't go to court
and this is because the
Crown Prosecution Service, or CPS,
they need to be satisfied that
there is sufficient evidence
to provide a realistic prospect
of conviction.
Their argument for not prosecuting
based on the fingermark
on the outside of the vehicle
might be that anyone could have
walked by and leaned on the vehicle,
leaving the mark.
In the past,
defence barristers argued about
who the evidence belonged to,
but now they focus on how
the evidence got there.
Could the evidence have been left
by someone other than
the person breaking into the car?
If there is any possibility
it could be someone else,
then the CPS tend not
to take these cases to court.
Forensic science
is constantly evolving.
In the future, it's possible that
many crimes will be solved
before they've even been committed,
as predictive software will mean
that police forces
will be able to anticipate when and
where a crime is likely to take place
and even who's likely to commit it.
Then there's our microbiome,
the tiny microbes in our gut,
which, according to
a new study Harvard,
can identify us as individuals
just like a fingerprint.
Despite the rapidly changing
world of forensics,
Linda says that there's one thing
that good forensic scientists
never forget...
That we're dealing
with real people's lives,
and we need to ensure
that we work
in an objective and unbiased way,
because if we get it wrong, it's
people's liberty that's at stake.